to present the award for the best
performance by an actor in a supporting
role the nice I mean the nurse from mash
whom you will soon see in the last the
red-hot lovers Sally Kellerman and the
star of man in the wilderness and the
soon-to-be-released Bloomfield
concert artists and a great friend
Richard Harris
in my country practically everybody puts
a barb or two or a shilling on a
sporting event myself I like the long
shots but I can think of a bookie who
might have taken my bet and what is
going to happen here tonight what mr.
Harris is trying to tell you is that
never before have all five nominees for
the Best Supporting Actor been nominated
for the very first time and those
gentlemen are Jeff Bridges in the last
picture show
Leonard Frye in Fiddler on the Roof
Richard Jaeckel and sometimes a great
notion Ben Johnson in the last picture
show and Roy Scheider in the French
Connection and the winner is Sally
Oh ain't that Purdy good evening ladies
and gentlemen
I'm very grateful to the Academy I had a
speech all rigged up for this but the
more I worked on it the phone year it
got so I I'd like to mention some people
that has made this all possible mr.
Peter Bogdanovich the director of the
last picture show his lovely wife Polly
mr. John Ford who had a lot to do with
my doing the show the entire cast and
crew and all of the folks down in an
attorney in Texas I think they deserve a
big mention
last but certainly not least Columbia
Pictures if you got a crew like that
behind you you can't be all bad and now
what I'm about to say probably will stir
up a lot of conversation around over the
country something I'd like to leave in
everyone's mind throughout the world
this couldn't have happened to a nicer
feller